today we're going to show you how to get
rid of your skin tags and warts very
quickly okay now many times it'll go
away every overnight or in a few days or
it may in certain circumstances take up
to two weeks to fully get rid of them
but during this process you're going to
find a lessening of these skin tags the
longer you do this now getting rid of
these skin tags are actually very easy
to do and it's a simple two ingredient
remedy okay but more importantly is to
understand
why you have skin tags or warts in the
first place a skin tag or a wart is an
indicator it's your body's way of
communicating that there's something
else going on that you should pay
attention to so the purpose of this
video is to really understand the why
behind the symptom so not only can you
get rid of it but to make sure it
doesn't come back because there are
other problems that are probably
existing right now in your body that are
related to this underlying cause
so first of all what do we know about
skin tags or warts well we know we have
a growth of cells
and the term for that is an anabolic
response okay anabolic means the growth
of something it's actually a mini little
tumor it's a benign tumor benign tumors
are not cancer cancer involves something
called a malignancy which it's spreading
out of control so a benign tumor happens
at a very certain location and it gets
to a certain size but it doesn't take
over the body and these skin tags
usually are on the folds of your skin on
your neck armpit
um but there can be anywhere as well it
can be in your mouth your esophagus the
trachea the larynx your private parts
you're groin they can be all over now
there is a high association between skin
tags and warts and HPV human papilloma
virus you have to realize that HPV are
not just one virus it's over like 130 or
140 different types of human
papillomaviruses so each one can create
different situations all right so what
else do we know about a skin tag well
definitely more common in women
so why is that what's the difference
between men and women well women have
more estrogen for one thing and also you
see a higher incidence of skin tags when
a woman gets pregnant which would also
validate this estrogen situation and
also estrogen is an anabolic hormone so
it makes cells grow and the more fat
that you have the more estrogen you're
going to make so if someone is
overweight they're going to make more
estrogen both men and women and the last
point about estrogen is that not only is
there a high risk factor for getting
skin tags there's a higher risk factor
of just having HPV and HPV related
cancers okay so there's that connection
as well but there's another interesting
piece of information relating to these
skin tags and that would be increase
risk of skin tags in conditions like
diabetes obesity and PCO OS polycystic
ovarian syndrome which is really related
to the underlying cause of diabetes and
obesity which is high levels of insulin
okay but under that is insulin
resistance now one study they did with
98 cases of people with skin tags nearly
all of them had insulin resistance okay
based on a test called Homa ir and I'll
put that study down below and so they
found a very very strong association
between skin tags and insulin resistance
skin tags and high triglycerides and
skin tags and obesity which basically
high triglycerides and obesity are
related to insulin resistance as well
now another thing that's interesting
about insulin resistance where you have
a situation where you have a lot of
insulin in the body that's compensating
for this insulin resistance in the cell
so when insulin is supposed to penetrate
the mitochondria the energy Factory of
the cell to make ATP which is energy it
doesn't do it to the degree it should
so then the bodies gets this feedback
loop and it starts making a lot of
insulin but it's not connecting with the
mitochondria and we don't have enough
insulin connecting with the mitochondria
you get lower numbers of mitochondria
you get dysfunctional mitochondria which
is at the heart of both cancer and the
nine tumors which are skin tags so I
believe that's the biggest mechanism of
why people get skin tags okay it's it
has to do with what's going on at the
mitochondrial level so I'm going to get
to the remedy next but I just want to
emphasize the importance of
understanding the mechanism behind skin
tags and what you need to do about it
you need to fix insulin resistance okay
as well as estrogen dominance if you
have that problem but chances are it's
going to be more of an insulin
resistance problem and the solution for
that is definitely getting on the
healthy version of the ketogenic diet as
well as intermittent fasting to make
sure that after you get rid of these
skin tags they don't come back all right
now let's talk about the remedy it's
really really simple you're just going
to be using two things iodine in garlic
what's interesting about iodine is not
only can It inhibit HPV
but it also can help regulate estrogen
and I'm going to recommend a type of
iodine that you can get at the pharmacy
drugstore it's called pobedome iodine
it's less toxic and it's very soluble
okay and they use it even to treat burns
so you're going to use that you're just
going to use a few drops you're going to
get a little container a little dish put
two drops of this iodine in it okay each
day and then you're going to take some
fresh garlic and crush a little bit of
it to get a couple drops okay so we're
going to mix a couple drops of garlic
with the iodine together okay you're
going to mix it up and then you're going
to take a little uh cotton swab put it
directly on the skin tag or wart and put
a Band-Aid or tape over it okay
and you're going to apply that same
mixture just twice a day now I'm going
to recommend that you keep it in the
refrigerator just to keep the uh the
garlic really fresh you don't have to
worry about the iodine but the garlic
needs to stay fresh and potent because
there's a certain phytonutrient called
allicin in the garlic that is doing all
the magic and so it's very anti-cancer
it's antiviral it does a lot now you're
going to notice after even a day of
using this that there's a significant
shrinkage of the skin tag if not
completely gone it really depends on how
bad you have insulin resistance okay it
could take up to two weeks but you will
see a lessening of the skin tag over
time now the next day I recommend that
you toss out the dish that you made the
previous day and make a fresh batch
couple drops of iodine a couple drops of
garlic juice fresh because that way we
can maintain the potency of the garlic
okay and you can just cut up this garlic
clove and just Crush different pieces of
it each day and it'll go a long way but
we want that garlic fresh and we're
gonna we're gonna put it on the area
topically put a little Band-Aid or a
piece of tape and you're just going to
keep repeating this applying it to the
surface of your skin for up to two weeks
if you need it for that long and you can
also use other things too other things
will work like zinc oxide uh apple cider
vinegar might work oregano oil will work
but I think you're going to see the best
results with garlic and this iodine now
a wart is also caused by a human
papillomavirus and you may need to shift
to a slightly different remedy if needed
maybe not but let's say the first remedy
doesn't work or you don't see any change
within one week then shift this other
remedy which is either one of two things
you can use salicylic acid you can get
it from the drugstore in little patches
or just Crush an aspirin up and put some
of this aspirin topically within some
water with a Band-Aid or a tape and
apply that that will tend to work or
there's an ancient plant you can get as
a remedy and it's called celandine okay
I mean if you had it fresh that would be
the ideal situation because you just
take
um one of the stems and you'll notice
that there's this oozing fluid out of
the stem
you would put that topically it's very
very potent to viruses and you put just
a little drop on that but a Band-Aid and
or tape but the most important thing
about this video and the emphasis is to
correct the underlying reason why you
have these in the first place and I
highly recommend you get started on this
right now while it's fresh in your mind
so I put the first video up on this
playlist right here check it out